Here are the more elaborate organization of the hardware resources inside a
computer system with an I/O Bus and a system Bus, and usually the system
Bus, is a synchronous communication device between the CPU and the memory.
The I/O bus is primarily intended for the devices to communicate with the CPU.
And the intent is that the individual needs of each of these devices, in terms
of the communication bandwidth that they may need,
is less than the cumulative bandwidth that may
be available for the CPU to communicate with
the memory. Or in other words, the system
bus has a communication bandwidth that is much
more than the communication bandwidth that's available in
the I/O bus. So the system bus is a high speed bus and it connects via a bridge
to the I/O bus. And this bridge itself, could be a specialized IO processor
for scheduling the devices that need to communicate
with the memory for instance, if it is
a DMA device or need to communicate with the CPU if it's a slow speed device.
So the role of the bridge is like a processor in itself. Controlling
who has access to this I/O bus among the set of devices that
maybe competing at the same time for attention by the CPU and
communicating the intent of these I/O devices either directly with
the memory or via the CPU. The I/O bus is typically lower speed
than the higher speed system bus. And the cumulative
bandwidth that is needed in the system bus is
usually much higher because it has to cater to
all the clients that may want to access the
memory, either from the CPU or from any of
these devices coming through this bridge. There may be
other high-speed devices, for example, a frame buffer, of
a graphics display that may also be hanging off of
the system bus due to the need for refreshing the screen in a rapid manner from
the memory. So in a nut shell, if you look at the internal organization of a
computer system that are going to be one or
more CPUs, whether it is a single-core machine
or multi-core machine or parallel machine and so
on. You're going to have one or more CPUs and
youre going to have a bunch of memory that the CPUs can access and there's
going to be a whole number of input-output devices. And device controllers that
allow these devices to communicate with the CPU, or
directly with the memory. And there are conduits, system bus and I/O bus,
for connecting these controllers to the CPU as well as
to the memory. Basically, these conduits allow ferrying data from the CPU to the
devices, or from the devices to the CPU, and between CPU and the memory,
as well as from the devices to the memory. This is why I mentioned
earlier that there is no difference in
the organization, regardless of the platform specifics,
the form factor may be different, or the intended use may be different
of a particular platform. But the internal
organization is pretty much going to look as
I've shown you here in terms of the hardware elements that are going to be
there as well as the connectivity that
you might see among these hardware elements.